okay in this video I'm going to make you
guys an expert on Loki the god of
stories from Marvel Comics and just for
good measure we're going to talk about
the most recent episode of Loki and how
it all fits together so spoilers for
Loki's most recent episode so the
question is what's the deal with Loki
the god of stories and where in the
world did this guy come from all right
this guy is ridiculously overpowered and
by the end of this video you'll
understand he's probably the most
powerful being to ever exist in the
history of Marvel Comics and is probably
right up there next to the one above all
but all of this goes back to a story
called Siege on Asgard or just Siege as
it sometimes known what had happened
here is that Loki as you know him the
trickster the god of Lies the dude with
the horns on his head he existed in this
way in Marvel Comics for decades but he
came to the realization that he was
trapped in this role of always being the
god of lies and never being able to win
and so in response to this he did two
things the first is that in the one-hot
comic Loki Siege number one he basically
manipulated Hela the goddess of Hell
most of you guys know her from the MCU
he manipulated her to have his name
removed from the book of hell because
he's not an honorable Warrior when he
died he wouldn't go to bhalla he would
go to the realm of hell and so by doing
this it meant that when he died he would
be reborn the second thing he did is he
allowed himself to die in an honorable
fashion by literally sacrificing his
life during the EV of Siege on Asgard
now following this going into Thor issue
number 617 Loki's reborn as a kid out
there in like Paris or something like
that he's a human he doesn't know
anything about himself and so Thor grabs
him he brings him back to Asgard and
restores some of his memories and so
what this did is it broke him free from
the chains of fate of being the god of
lies and tricks because now his story
could basically start over right he
hadn't been the god of Lies for eon and
eons he could be whatever he wanted to
be now in the journey into mystery story
which was relaunched to tell the
adventures of like kid Loki what ended
up happening is at an issue
622 where kid Loki had met this quote
unquote echo of his former self which
seemed to be just kind of like a memory
or something like that that existed out
there that this Eko right the original
Loki told kid Loki my whole plan was for
my physical form to Die My Mind in
Essence would remain alive and then my
physical body would be reborn as you so
that at a future point in time I could
take over your body kid Loki rejects
this right he doesn't want to have
anything to do with this so quite
literally as crazy as it's going to
sound kid Loki takes the mind in essence
of his former self and confines it to a
crow and then he changes its name to iol
Loki spelled backwards because the old
Loki represents the inverse right the
evil version of Loki whereas kid Loki is
like a good guy he's trying to be a hero
now all this comes to a head in journey
into mystery issue number
645 and the reason why is because with
kid Loki rejecting the idea of the
original Loki to sacrifice himself and
allow the original Loki to inhabit his
body the original Loki as a crow went
and did his own scheme what you end up
finding out is that kid Loki had at some
point along the line after the events of
fear itself which we don't need to get
into here he had taken all the fear and
all the doubt that he had about himself
and confined it into something called
The Fear crown and then kept it hidden
for safekeeping that the original Loki
once he learned about this went to the
demon Mesto and Mesto was told if you
gain this fear Crown you can in turn
unleash hell on Earth which is exactly
what Mesto tried to do he tried to
become the new Satan but kid Loki came
to the realization that the only way to
destroy the fear Crown was to destroy
himself and so in issue number 645 he
agreed to the deal with the original
Loki he basically allowed the original
Loki to take over his entire mind and
body kid Loki by all senters of
measurement ceased to exist and the
original Loki was now fully reborn on
Earth in the form of a child albeit
going by the name eel the kicker about
all this is the original Loki did not
expect to feel guilt and shame for his
actions and basically killing this
younger version of himself but he did
and so following that going over the
course of kid Loki's appearances in
Marvel Comics that's why you see him
joining things like Young Avengers and
so on and so forth It's the original
Loki trying to make amends not just for
destroying his younger self but all of
his past misdeeds now this goes into
Loki volume 3 issues 2-5 this is where
the god of stories landscape begins to
pick up and what you have is Loki who's
brought by two Cosmic entities named
then and now to a place called the house
of ideas it turns out to be a false
House of ideas and we'll explain why
that matters here in a second but the
power he's given here is to basically
add to What's called the book of Loki
basically chronicling his own Adventures
that after he had become kid Loki and
then grown into a teenager and all that
kind of stuff he basically became the
king of yodenheim and was just bored out
of his mind but that was destined to be
his existence
by making a deal with then and now what
it does is it allows him to add pages in
effect any untold story now becomes real
so if for example he decides to write
into the books of Loki Once Upon a Time
in the distant past I turned Thor into a
cockroach Thor would suddenly have this
memory that at some point in his distant
past he was a cockroach right that's how
that power worked it's already kind of
op it becomes even more overpowered
because in the immortal Thor run which
is recently just launched what you end
up learning is that Loki realizes that
the house of ideas of then and now is
not real that it was a false House of
ideas he actually visits the real house
of ideas and what he's given is the real
God of stories power what this means is
that Loki now has the power to rewrite
any existing event within the confines
of Marvel comics on either a universe or
seemingly a multiversal scale or even
rewrite past events to where they now
become real so if some event was
transpiring right now in Marvel Comics
Loki can just change it on a whim like
that he is as close as anybody gets to
being the one above all and in fact I
would argue he's equal in power to the
one above all but there are caveats here
if Loki changes something in Marvel
Comics in the here and now it will have
an effect on the future what that effect
is he doesn't know because it's one
thing to be the god of stories it's
another to be all knowing and to know
exactly how every eventuality of every
possible change in every timeline will
ultimately play out but with that power
alone he can write people into existence
he can write people out of existence he
can change the origins of any characters
that exist out there this guy is by all
standers of measurement a writer of
Marvel Comics living inside the Marvel
Comics universe right it's crazy how
powerful he is now let's take all that
information and let's apply this to
what's going on in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe right now so as we know with
the most recent episode of Loki in
season 2 Loki has now gained control of
his ability to time slip in effect he
can travel back and forth in time at a
win he can go anywhere he wants to along
the timeline and I would go so far as to
argue that because he gained this power
in a place that is not bound by space or
time in the TVA he can actually jump
between realities he can go from one
Universe to the next and any point in
time which makes him a ridiculously
powerful character now in my mind
because the Marvel Cinematic Universe is
far more toned down in terms of the
grandiosity of the kind of things that
you see in Marvel Comics the idea of him
making the statement I can change the
story has less to do with him sitting
down with a piece of paper and just
rewriting the entirety of history and is
more to do with him just going to the
past and changing something so what is
it that he's going to do my thought here
is this I think that what Loki is going
to do is he's going to come to this
realization if he hasn't already that
the death of he who remains and the idea
that the Multiverse returns and all
those universes are being compacted into
a loom that just wasn't built to handle
all those eventualities at one point in
time that the destruction of the Loom
the end of all time in existence is the
eventuality of he who remains death
there's no way to stop that from
happening anytime he dies this is
exactly what happens and so because of
that he is going to go back and he could
potentially try to stop Sylvie from
killing he who remains but the problem
with this is that if he who remains
continues to live that means the sacred
timeline stays intact the only timelines
that are allowed to exist are the
timelines that result in the creation of
he who remains any timeline that results
in any variant of Kang other than he who
remains is pruned but that flies in the
face of what we saw at the end of
Ant-Man and was quantam Mania all those
Varian of Kang popping back up so what
that means to me is the Multiverse has
to return I think he who remains is
going to stay dead Loki is going to go
back to the moment when the loom was
about to explode or some point after the
death of he who remains and he's going
to say we just have to shut the loom
down let the Multiverse Run free let all
the different universes come into
existence now is that trading one threat
for another yes but the guaranteed
eventual destruction and the unraveling
of all of time in existence is a far
more severe threat than just a bunch of
crazy guys teaming up and running around
the Multiverse trying to conquer it
right and so with the Multiverse running
free this now allows all those variants
of King to start popping up what I think
is going to happen and I said this two
years ago long before this information
is coming out now so I just want to say
I'm not even saying this because of the
information that's out now no man I
called this two years ago that Loki in
realizing the threat of the variant
kangs that exist out there is going to
form the multiversal Avengers he's going
to either call them the Exiles or
they'll just be the multiversal Avengers
whatever you want to call them right
whatever name is given to them but it's
going to quite literally be kind of like
Robert dasta's multiversal Avengers from
Jonathan Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers the collapse of all things
except this time they're not going to be
killed they're not going to be like
eradicated in one Fell Swoop they'll
survive for longer than a comic book but
still right Loki is going to form the
multiversal Avengers that Avengers team
is going to go to war against the Kings
and it will quite literally like the
whole Secret Wars will be called that
because it'll be a war that exists in
secret because the general public
doesn't know about it a multiversal war
of all the superheroes that Loki can
find every variant of Captain America
that hasn't been killed by some variant
of Kang across the Multiverse every
variant of Iron Man every variant of
Spider-Man all those guys right I mean
just kind of imagine that man like
imagine imagine Miles Morales from into
the spider-verse right teaming up with
Tom Holland and Toby Maguire and Andrew
Garfield who a lot of you guys like now
but only because of the newest
Spider-Man movie you never liked him
before so you don't get to ride on this
ride imagine that the whole spider verse
teaming up with like the whole Iron Man
verse right Rober Downey Jr comes back
along with however many versions exist
right like that combined with like every
variant of Captain America so like Chris
Evans comes back all the different
variants of the Fantastic Four like
imagine that dude imagine that all those
guys facing off against all these Kings
that's what I think is going to happen
in secret Wars with that being said guys
we're going to bring this to an end let
me know what you guys think down in the
comments section and I will catch you
all later peace